hey guys I'm Ryan Wright I'm here today
cuz I got no sleep cuz I just could not
believe the drama that is going on in
this reactor a world that's a symbol
okay so like there's a bunch of reactors
out there now like when I first started
it was like me and Gator Martin and
Tyrone now there's like a [ __ ] ton of
people so the reactors they all get
along they all love each other but now
there's some drama happening there's
some legit drama happening that I was
like you know for those who don't know
about it they need to know people are
like we should just put an end to this
we shouldn't talk about it anymore
we should have fight about it anymore
and I was like [ __ ] that I'm gonna add
fuel to the fire so here's what you guys
might not know there's a reactor named
jinx right jinx put out a challenge when
he was like at seven to nine thousand
songs I forgot we're basically saying
he's gonna pass like Tyrone he's coming
after him Tyrone as you guys know it was
the first reactor to pass 100k anyway
now he's like at close to 160 km it--be
past that for all I know
jinx puts out this challenge right and
then all of a sudden I didn't know this
till yesterday
jinx past a hundred thousand subscribers
then I look at his channel and I'm like
oh I passed the hundred thousand today
and I look as China's had a hundred two
thousand I'm like whoa this guy jumped
up 2k and one day I noticed so silly I
love a series this is Kevin and then the
other reactor aqus on the black man from
Japan he puts out a video pretty much
talking about how he thinks there's a
reactor out there I'm pretty sure this
is what he did actually didn't catch off
it's on the video but here's what I
heard there's a reactor out there who's
buying box and if you guys know what
that means that means they're buying
fake subscribers they're advertised as
real selves they're not [ __ ] real
subs they're fake subs they just make
your numbers look pretty you can also do
that you can buy views you can buy likes
everyone was like this is crazy jinx is
jumping up like thousands of subscribers
a day
is like not likely so people are
thinking he's buying soon he's buying
some BOTS Tyrone Magnus does a video
about how he would never buy BOTS
he didn't mention jinx though but we all
knew he was talking about jinx and then
jinx does a video saying like all these
people are hating on me and they're just
jealous you want to be a man then holler
at me he didn't mention Tyrone but we
all knew he was talking about Tyrone
Anaka son and then Tyrone posted a video
or he flat-out calls out jinx and just
starts talking about why he thinks he
got the box and everything it is a
little suspicious when I checked he was
at 100 mm and then I'm looking through
all this [ __ ] and then a couple hours
later he's at a hundred six thousand
subscribers so he jumps up like six
thousand subscribers in one day that is
pretty suspicious let me see where he's
at now okay okay he jumps up 106 Tyrone
puts his video out right and now he was
jumping up thousands of subscribers a
day now he is at 100 six thousand six
hundred forty nine so all of a sudden
his channel stopped jumping up in
subscribers now I'm not saying jinx got
some box but this does make it look like
that he might have gotten some so jinkx
does a video saying y'all hated on me
right but jinx gave me a shout-out in
this video so I was like oh I shouldn't
get involved because this guy likes me
still and then Tyrone does a reaction to
that video and Tyrone's like ryan right
knows what's up and I was like oh this
this is some serious drama and I was
like you know what I want to get
involved in the fight here's my take on
this whole thing okay
you guys want to know the truth you guys
want to know the legit truth of
everything that's going on about if jinx
got BOTS or not I'm here to tell you
that he did you know why there's all my
subscribers I bought them too I bought
every single one of my subs not one of
them is real if there's comments that's
my account and I just created those
accounts and posted comments just to
make it look like people like me I'm a
very lonely person and you know what
everyone else got their boss - Tyrone
man
this key bottle is subscribe you really
think he's got that many subscribers he
bought every single one of them acha
song he bought all his subs Gator Martin
he didn't have enough money to buy all
this subs you got most of his subs so
jinx it's okay if you bought some
subscribers you know why because we all
have bought our subscribers I don't have
one real sub I just use it as an excuse
to bring girls on this channel it just
makes me look good no I'm of course
kidding you guys want to know my real
opinion on this alright here's my real
opinion of what's going on jinx
let's say he did buy these subscribers
he jumps up thousands of subsidy all the
sudden right now is that unlikely yes
very unlikely that that is real is it
impossible no it is not impossible
now did he do it maybe maybe not me
personally I'm very grateful for the
amount of subscribers that this channel
has been getting daily the past few days
it's been jumping up around 1,200 to
1,300 subscribers a day which is pretty
[ __ ] insane to me I don't know if he
did it you know did he do it me me maybe
not is he black
yes he is does he like my controls maybe
maybe not
does he have a bigger [ __ ] and Tyrone I
don't know is he's smaller than Tyrone
hi boys
yeah was Jesus real sure what's it the
son of God maybe that's a point around
opinions I'm bringing all this up for no
apparent reason
here's what I think here's what I think
I don't give a [ __ ] about his channel
that doesn't mean that I don't like him
or I don't care about him or that I
don't like you know whatever I don't
care if he got subscribers or not I
really don't you know why cuz that ain't
my focus when I do this channel I don't
give a [ __ ] about anyone else's numbers
Tyrone Magnus he's been ahead of me for
god knows how long he's he like stays
exactly thirty five thousand subs ahead
of me like all the time and that's cool
that's really cool and I'm fine with
that
jinx he could pass me in subscribers
whether they're real or not I don't give
[ __ ] and I mean that you know why
because I only do this channel for you
guys for you guys that are subscribed
already Tyrone and I talked in the phone
for like an hour and a half a while ago
and I think I said something that might
have miscommunicated to him where he he
thought I was pretty much saying that I
focus on getting views and I guess it
could come down to that but what I was
really meant to say was I focus on those
who are already subscribed you know you
could have a large subscriber is why I
don't care to buy BOTS or anything to
make my subscriber number look prettier
because I could have a [ __ ] ton of subs
but I care about how many of those subs
are consistently watching the real
rejects videos that's what I care about
I take care about tending to the guys
and girls who are already subbed and I
want to get as many of you guys to
consistently keep watching the videos
some people want to gather more so some
people want to get more views I just
care about the retention rate with
jinxes YouTube channel business you
numerical [ __ ] he wants if you got the
subs or not it doesn't matter to me cuz
it's just a number at the end of the day
Tyrone he can keep doing his thing I
love Tyrone a lot and he could stay in
the sub count but I noticed him and I
still get similar amount of views and
the reason why is because I only give a
[ __ ] about my channel and about what's
going on with you guys now here is where
it would have set me with jinx if jinx
was going out there acting like he's top
dog and that he's the [ __ ] and that he
rules everyone else and he's talking
smack that's when I would be a little
bit upset because like in this whole
reactor world which is so silly to me
still it's a bunch of people doing
reactions this whole reactor world
that's come down to like the few main
people tyrone myself gator Hakkasan and
jinx
now if jinx did buy subs he wouldn't be
part of this category of the 5 main
people who do reactions right at the end
of the day you know what it doesn't
matter it don't it doesn't [ __ ]
matter to me and here's what I say if
you guys are subscribed jinx just stay
[ __ ] subscribe
lady doesn't matter I'm not trying to
get him to lose more subs and I'm not
saying he did it well I'm saying is is
if you like the guys content it doesn't
matter if his subscriber count is fake
or not if you like his content keep
watching his videos if you have lost
respect for him because of a theory then
okay unsubscribe but at the end of the
day I'm not here to tell you that jinx
did it or not I'm here to say that it
doesn't matter to me if jinx did it or
not because you know what that's his
business and he'll have to live with the
consequences if he did do it he's really
going out there saying he didn't do it
like I said it's suspicious definitely
saying that granny gave me a shout-out
but it is suspicious
Tyrone's pretty dead certain he did it
sounds like acha song is too but you
know what i don't care
jinx you keep doing what you got to do
well thank you guys for tuning and I
want to get my two cents of the reactor
world drama if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter where I'm trying
to get product placement by getting a
certain amount of followers bagels I
would love to get product placement from
bagel companies watch I can help promote
you bagels bagels are amazing they're
easy to cook you just put them in the
toaster heat him up put some butter or
cream cheese or even jelly on it but you
know what I like to do every time before
I have sex I warm up my penis by putting
my penis in between this hole so Western
bagel if you're looking for a sponsor
I'm your guy 1 million subscribers what
nothing that's not my cat wrist
that's not my catchphrase sorry if you
like what you see here and you want to
see more click right here to see it up
that's Jeremy John's gonna click on this
button I might take to subscribe that's
unfortunately my catchphrase